Awesome. All right. Welcome to
the DDPS seminar everyone.
Before we introduce our invited
speaker, let's go over some
rules and logistics. First of
all, please mute yourself during
the talk unless you have
questions. You have questions.
If you have questions you are
welcome to mute and ask
otherwise, please use the chat
room to post your questions so
that we can address them in q&a
session at the end. Second,
today's GDPR seminar is open to
external audiences therefore no
classified discussion is
allowed. So please watch out.
Finally, the talk today will be
recorded and uploaded in our
YouTube channel. That's about
it. Now let me introduce our
speaker today. It is an honor to
host dispenser brings bring
Gilson who is an assistant
professor in the College of
Computing at Georgia Tech.
Previously, he was a senior
postdoctoral researcher at
Caltech with Tim colonias a
visiting researcher at MIT with
chemists SubSys and a
postdoctoral researcher at the
Center for exascale simulation
of plasma coupled combustion
with Carlos Pantanal and then
Bodoni he received his PhD and
MSc in theoretical and applied
mechanics from the University of
Illinois at Urbana Champaign in
2017 and 2000 kin working with
the Jonathan fluid. In 2013. He
received a bachelor's in science
degree in both mechanical
engineering and mathematics from
the University of Michigan's
Dearborn. Spencer won a few
awards like the Young
Investigator Award from Oak
Ridge National Lab, the UI UC
Outstanding Dissertation Award
and the UC has an RF our full
research in fluid dynamics.
Today Spencer will talk about
comparative physics informed
networks, which is a very
interesting topic. Please enjoy
and expect a wonderful talk now
without further ado, let me pass
the baton to Spencer, by asking
one random person really, really
random questions. That random
question is what is the most e
rational superstitions you have?
If you have one?
Most irrational superstition
that I have. I'm not a very
superstitious person. Yes. But I
guess maybe most scientists
aren't. I don't know how to
answer that question.
Let me ask another question.
Okay.
You got it. Superstitious that
consciousness is not real? How
about that?
Oh, okay.
So weird. It's, it's a weird
it's a weird, weird answer. But
I think it's a it may be a
somewhat controversial one. So
I think I make sense. It's a
perfect answer for the viewer
the question, okay. Stacy's
yours. Thank you young soon.
Okay. Well, thanks, everyone,
for having me. And thanks for
the nice introduction. So
physics and formed neural
networks are a hot topic as Jung
Soo has alluded to. And so we're
gonna get down to some nitty
gritty details here about what I
think is going on in this
research area. And maybe some of
the problems that exist and some
potential solutions to them,
which I understand is a bit
vague, but we'll get there.
First, will do the
acknowledgments at the
beginning. So I don't forget. So
really, the brains behind this
operation are two outstanding
students, seizing and Yash
cathartic. They are two great
students that work in my
research group. I also have an
outstanding collaborator,
Professor Florian Schafer, who
is also in the same department
as I am and sitting a couple of
offices away from me right now.
So I'm very grateful for them.
And they contributed to this
work as well. And there's a
paper that is associated with
much of this work that you can
refer to as as you see fit. It's
on the archive, and it was just
accepted to iClear 2023. Okay,
so let's first do just a quick
overview of what type of physics
and form neural network is, even
though maybe many people know
but we'll do a quick
introduction. So the idea of a
physics form neural network is
simply that, number one, your
task is that you want to solve a
PDE and The way you're going to
do it is you're going to encode
the solution to that PDE into a
neural network, the neural
network doesn't necessarily have
a very complicated topology,
it's in many cases, just a multi
layer perceptron, though some
people have experimented with
different types of
architectures. But at the end of
the day, it's just a neural
network in which you are
encoding the solution to a PDE
via training. And that's it. And
then so in the way that this is
done, is that the loss function
for the training of this PDE is
simply the mean squared error.
So the difference between the
exact solution to the PDE and,
and the one that you observed,
so this is but and so the magic
of this, or the seeming magic of
this, is that through
backpropagation, you can get the
all of these, you can accumulate
the derivatives to any partial
differential equation, you may
have an ad, or ordinary
differential equation, such that
you don't actually need to
really have any data on hand,
all you really need to have is
the PDE. And then I can then
formulate what solutions or I
can create a neural net, I train
a neural network to represent
its solution, which is a really
clever little trick that sort of
bypasses problems of oh, well,
how do I come up with so called
deal truth data, and so on, and
so forth. And because of its
simplicity, this is why it's so
popular seemingly these days.
But now, I thought, I'd be
remiss without doing a little
bit of archaeology here. So the
idea of introducing physic
physical constraints, in this
case, a partial differential
equation. But of course, one can
imagine other physical
constraints, being integrated
into a artificial neural network
is actually a rather old idea,
or at least rather ruled by, by
neural networks, standards,
artificial neural network
standards, and the research in
the field. So if we actually go
back to 1994, Thompson and
Kramer, they introduced these
ideas of intermediate variables
and residual modeling, as a way
of actually solving for for
models. And now, they weren't
necessarily solving PDS that may
have been beyond their
computational capabilities at
the time, but they had this very
similar fundamental idea. And so
and so that was quite
interesting. And it didn't
really gain a tremendous
traction at the time, but they
had seemingly the core idea
there that that comment seems to
come ever so naturally to us,
once, once, you're told that at
the very least, there's also
this idea of physics based pre
processing, where you inject
some prior physical knowledge,
and then and then you train your
neural network model. So you do
this sort of ahead of time
instead of during training. And
so that that also has been
around for a long time, at least
since 1998, if not earlier. And
so humans have, we have this
idea that if our neural network
isn't really doing what we want
to maybe what we can do is we
can just inject some physics in
some sense, or some sort of
mathematical representation of
that physics. And that will make
things better. And so it turns
out that that idea is not
extremely new.
And
we can go on and on in 2005,
folks, came up with the idea of
a finite element neural network
where all of the weights that
compose the neural network, were
actually pre computed because
people had an idea of what they
should be to begin with, because
people under have understood
finite element methods for a
long time. So people tried that
as well and had some success.
And then we go further and
further. And there was some work
in 2007, where people were
incorporating physical models as
neural network constraints and
had more and more successes as
more computational resources
were available. So here, we're
looking at something like a
constitutive law on the top in
order to get some temperature of
a material. So none of these
specific applications or ideas
notwithstanding, the reason that
perhaps they didn't get a ton of
traction, is because maybe we
just weren't quite ready for
them. And or we didn't, both in
terms of sort of computational
horsepower, or in terms of the
software tooling needed in order
to make them easy to create. But
it just so happens around, maybe
the mid 2010s that these types
of tools became common, some
thinking of things like pytorch
and TensorFlow and so on, as
well as GPUs started exploding
onto the scene where now sort of
everyone can have access to GPU
or a small cluster of GPUs, in
order to train these things in
between the two, it sort of was
just the right sort of mixture
of things in order to pop out
these things deemed physics and
formed neural networks, which is
a quite similar idea, but it was
just really came in at the right
time. And, and, and showed all
sorts of great examples about
what these things can do. And so
this is, of course, the the
quite now famous paper of
veracity prior to cartus, and
George Krennic, daucus, that I
think many of us are familiar
with. So pins pop into the scene
until the 19, though the
archived version of their paper
was, I believe, 2017. And so
since then, we've had a bit of a
research explosion in this area,
basically, all of these papers
in this review, so you can find
this on the archive, and this is
a separate paper are, are
purporting to, to try to sort of
hammer away at as they're
attempting to hammer away at
this problem. And in all sorts
of from basically every
different angle. And I think
we're going to get to, in this
talk, we're gonna get to the
point of why so many of these
papers exist, why we're looking
at those references here, at
least on this slide into the
three hundreds. So part of this
is because this tool is
powerful, but part of it is
because it actually needs some
help. So I'm going to get to
that next. Okay, so, so this is
to bring us back after this
short history lesson. This is
again, what a physics informed
neural network looks like. And,
and I'll recall to you that this
MSC here stands for mean squared
error. So this is like an L two
error on basically the
difference between the solution
or the residual of a PDE. So
maybe you want to focus on this
part where my pointer is this f
minus Laplace you. So here,
we're just solving up for song
like equation. So this is the
PDE residual, and then this
other term is just sitting in
for the boundary conditions,
perhaps, is not especially
important. But here this thing
in the loss function, which is
really the main meat of what
makes up a neural network, and
certainly how it is trained, is,
is what's going on here. And so
I, I suggest, and I hope to show
some evidence that this is
actually part of the crux of
what will become a problem.
Okay, so the problem here
is that be these physics and
form neural networks, if I give
them a PDE, if I give them an
IV, a stokes equations, if they
give, if I give it even,
seemingly sometimes quite
benign, PDE s, or even odd is
that it will struggle to come up
with a accurate representation
for the solution, it will the
lot. And what I mean by that is
essentially that the loss
function will actually not
decrease. Too, a very low level.
So here, we're thinking about
something on the order of like
1% l to error. And of course, it
can be much worse than this.
There are some cases where some
PDS just do not train at all. So
you start off with some error,
and then nothing basically,
nothing happens as you go
through training. And this is
well documented, I put some
example papers here, there's
probably been even more since
since I first created the slide
like a couple of months ago. So.
So this is well documented. And
the question is, well, what's
going on here? Why can't I train
my neural network my pin to
represent this PDE wouldn't be
so great if I could, and it
turns out that it's not really
clear what the reason is,
because it's sometimes sort of
puts its head in into it butts
its head into seemingly benign
PDS whereas for more complicated
looking PDE, everything is just
fine. And you get all sorts in
the training error is quite low
and everyone's happy. So the
question is what what is going
on here?
So how do
we fix this thing? And I hope to
talk about that next. Okay. So,
my suspicion here, which I hope
to convince you of is that the
main cause of this problem is
that these problems are poorly
conditioned. So the pin loss
function is this L to like error
or this squared error involving
differential operators. Of
course, they can be of higher
differential order, which would
only make the problem worse. And
so but then, at the end of the
day, Eight the problem we're
actually trying to solve. So if
we just think about this in the
context of a discretize, linear
problem and discretize, linear
differential operator, so
something, again, seemingly
benign, in this case, upasana
equation, then, then this is the
problem that you're trying to
solve here, right. And so we
know that this is the solution
to this minimization problem.
And if you put this thing
through gradient descent, this
is going to be essentially what
gets computed and the problem
that that tries to get solved.
Now, and you're solving here for
you, that's the solution field
that you want. And you can have
the once you actually have that
thing, you can evaluate it
anywhere and say space, or if
this was the pine time
independent, you could evaluate
it in time, and so on, and so
forth. But, but if we remember
our numerical linear algebra, we
see that there's something quite
nasty about this, this this
problem, which is that this A
transpose A inverse is actually
a quite nasty thing. This is
akin to solving the normal
equations for a linear system,
which squares the condition
number of that operator. So if A
is encoding any differential
information, this is we're now
squaring that condition number,
which is something that we all
learned that we don't want to
do, sometimes when in during our
schooling, and so this is
essentially what's happening
every step through evaluating
the last and doing your gradient
descent or however you would
like to optimize your, your
neural network, your your pin.
Okay, so this seems to be a key
a problem to what's going on.
And so, instead, a way to fix
this, partially is to get rid of
this L two type business. But
the problem is that you don't
really want to give up this L
two type property, because it
has this nice convexity
properties. And an L two is nice
for all sorts of other reasons.
So you don't really want to
leave the L two space. And
instead, you'd like to solve
this and perhaps a different
way. And so this is where we're,
I think a reformulation of it,
otherwise, the same problem is
beneficial. And so here we are
recasting the same problem, as
instead a mini max minimization
problem. So the minimax problem
solution to the same problem. So
here, we are minimizing now the
solution to this PDE, where here
pi steps in as the solution. So
this is still the PDE residual
in the parentheses. And then D
serves as something that looks
like a discriminator that is
imposing penalties onto this
thing. And so this is a so
called mini max problem where
the D is trying to penalize
solutions that are poor. So it's
trying to just try to penalize
mistakes that are made by the
approximation pi. And vice
versa. Pi is trying to minimize
the terms that are in
parentheses, such that this is
such that this is small. And so
this is a back and forth game
that is going on between these
two agents. And so if you recast
this minimax game into its
linear formulation, which is is
what's shown here, then it turns
out that the condition number of
this linear system has the same
condition number as the original
derivative operator. And so
things are are better posed. And
so that can save quite a bit of
heartache. And I'll I hope to
show you some examples about why
why that that that are
compelling that suggests that
this is important. Okay, so the
next question is that, that we
need to implement this thing. So
we have here, this minimax game
and the top left, here's our PDE
residual for our sort of toy
PDE. The are our Poisson
problem. And we have our
discriminator hanging out here.
And this is what the
architecture looks like. So now
we have two multi layer
perceptrons. In this case, one
serves as a neural network
representing the discriminator.
And the other serves as what we
what is our good friend, the pin
that is going to give us the
solution, in this case pie. But
otherwise, they're up to the
same business except that they
are now competing. But now we
see that the loss function looks
a little bit different. We have
products here, for example,
between D, the discriminator,
and the the residual between the
the residual of the PDE that we
hope to solve. So we see that
this no longer looks like an L
two type mean squared loss
function. This looks different.
So that's what the architecture
looks like. And now the next
question is How does one
actually go about optimizing
such a type of game between this
discriminator and this pin
network. And so that's where
this idea of competitive
optimization comes in. So it
turns out that this is a quite
necessary task. And I'll make
the argument for that in a
moment. But what one can imagine
in the sea pin instance, that's
what we call it, these
competitive pins is that the
discriminator is acting as one
agent that is trying to do
what's in its best interest,
which is to penalize the
mistakes of mismatching the
solution to the PDE. And the y
is the actual PD residual, which
is trying to be as small as
possible. So these, this x and
y, these two agents, x and y are
in competition with each other.
Okay, and so one can think about
this as sort of like a cat, and
a mouse, where the mouse is this
Agent X, and the y is, is the
cat. And, and they're each
hoping to minimize their
respective loss functions f and
g, because the cat wants to get
the mouse, and the mouse does
not want to be gotten by the
cat. So so. So the thing to
notice here is that the loss of
each of these two apps and the
GS depends on what the other one
does. And so it turns out that
this is rather important. So
what they had, or what the mouse
does influences what the cat
should do next, and vice versa.
So and this can go back and
forth. Actually, if you think
about this, and sort of finite
time steps, this can go back and
forth sort of infinitely many
times, like, what would I do if
what would if he knew what I was
going to do, and back and forth,
and back and forth, and back and
forth, until you reach an
equilibrium? Okay, but we're
gonna get to that a little bit
more in a moment. But, but I'd
like to get into just a little
bit more detail here, because I
think it's helpful. So one thing
to notice here is that these two
agents, they have conflicting
goals. So what what is good for
the mouse is bad for the cat and
vice versa, which is shown here
as the they are basically, in
essence, opposite types of loss
functions, which again, are akin
to our sequence and since. And,
and so one way of viewing this
is, okay, well, why can't I just
do my regular gradient descent
type of algorithms or something
like them, in order to solve
this problem. So let's look at
what regular gradient descent or
what I like to call simultaneous
gradient descent, looks like for
for such a problem with two
agents. So here, we have the
update on x, and on the left,
and the update on y on the
right. And so what you see is
that the what what the x will do
only depends on what what the y
did at the previous step. So the
next the basically, the update
only depends on y or the
previous step. And vice versa, y
only depends on what x did at
the previous step. Okay, and so
we can see that if one actually
goes through with this strategy
that is in these that's embodied
in these two little equations,
that this strategy actually
diverge is even on quite simple
examples. So if the loss
function of F, H, and F is just
this inner product between X and
Y, which happens to be at odds
with the loss function of g, so
let's just define this. So
there's like a triple equality
here, as minus g because they
want to do opposite things, they
have opposite objectives, then
this, this thing even diverges
here. And so that's what's shown
in the picture, where here
basically, the state of the
Agent X, and the agent y is
plotted on this two dimensional
axis. So that makes up one
circle here. And then the arrow
represents the direction that
the basically the the loss
functions are pointing you in.
But we see that this this
basically divergence in this
spiral, like fashion, and the
reason for that is because for
example, if agent F were to play
in a in for example, in this in
Rock, Paper, Scissors, if the
agent
app were to play rock, then the
agent why word art would know
that next to pick paper. And
then after agent observes that
agent y, or Jeep pick paper, it
would then pick scissor and back
and forth and back and forth,
and back and forth. And not only
would you not converge, but you
would actually diverge in this
sort of spiral like fashion. So
this type of typical gradient
descent does not work on these
types of game formulations that
I've laid out in the previous
slides. Oh, okay. So then the
question is, how does one
linearize a game such that we
can get some type of gradient
descent descent like algorithm
because we know they are useful?
In order to carry out this
optimization in a way that
doesn't have these nasty
properties, and perhaps one
that's even kind of good. So one
idea is to just have one agent.
So and where the optimal
strategy is just the
regularized, linear local
approximation of what it should
be doing. And the other is to
have two agents where the
optimal strategies are
linearized local approximations
for both of the agents. But then
the question remains, how do you
actually linearize in order to,
to deal with these problems. And
so I'm going to briefly go
through the math of of how these
terms show up. And hopefully
that makes things a bit more
interactive, and more and more
interesting. And so here, let's
look at what is basically
essentially, straightforward
gradient descent on the, the
update to Agent X and the update
to agent y on the top and bottom
respectively. And so, here,
well, what we see is that if
this is linear for one agent,
then it is actually linear for
two agents. So this is just the
gradient, what you're looking at
at the top is just the gradient
descent update for so how x
should change. And here, this is
just sort of the truncated
Taylor series. So you have the
argument of the objective
function f. And then you have
your your gradient terms and x
and y that show up evaluated, of
course, at x sub k y sub k, and
then you have this
regularization term that
basically enforces or penalizes
good or bad behavior, which
looks like this inner product
term. So this, this sort of
corresponds to how big of a step
you would take, given the
competence that you have in
your, in your objective
function. And the same thing is
on the bottom, except now we're
looking at G's instead of apps.
And we're looking at why is it
set of axes, but otherwise,
things are the same. And we
still end up with these two
terms showing up here except
again, with with the G. Okay,
and so I think the the
interesting part that will that
will come up here is that if you
do this with sort of normal
gradient descent, then and you
and you linearize, this problem,
what you will find is that all
of these cross terms, the terms
that pas perspective that that
potentially could give the
information about what the cat
should do, knowing what the
mouse would do, and what the
mouse should do, knowing what
the cat should do, are actually
vanish, because this term does
not depend on why. And then this
term is evaluated such that is
not evaluated at any, this
derivative vanishes, because
it's constant with respect to x,
and vice versa here. So this
term ends up being a constant,
it goes away, this derivative
with respect to x goes away. And
so the only terms that you hold
on to are the normalization
terms, of course, and then these
highlighted terms that are
basically what we already went
through, they're the terms that
say, Okay, well, I'm the cat. So
I know that I should be doing
such and such. But it's not
taking in this, this intrinsic,
missing information about what
the cat would do, knowing what
the what the mouse would do. And
vice versa. There's no sort of
cross terms that exist here. So
this actually just turns in the
same goes for the mouse on the
bottom. And so this just turns
into simultaneous gradient
descent, once again. But then,
the interesting part is that
there's there's no reason
there's, there's actually
additional terms that can be
kept that are linear here. So
the additional terms are these
cross derivatives, in this case,
T x y of the second derivative
operator, that are shown in the
middle here. And these represent
what the cat would do knowing
what the mouse would do, and
vice versa. And they show up in
both the both the top and the
bottom terms. One thing to
notice here is that even though
this represents a Hashem, it
only represents the off diagonal
terms. So and so the there's,
this is still linear, it is not
nonlinear, and it doesn't result
in any other nasty second order
derivatives. Okay, and so this,
this allows them basically both
to peek at each other and go
back and forth, back and forth
in order to, to to make
basically the best update. And
now, and so this is an
interactive type of procedure.
Now, there's only one step left
in this in this business, which
is to find the Nash equilibrium,
which is that if I know that you
know that I know that you know
about the steps that I'm going
to make next then you can
iterate this over and over and
over again to find the Nash
equilibrium where it no longer
or makes sense for me to move in
a certain direction, because
knowing what you would do next,
I would do nothing different,
and vice versa. So, in this
case, both players are satisfied
with their positions, and then
you make an update. And so it
turns out that you can just get
this from a truncated value
decomposition and taking that to
an infinite power, and then you
get a Nash equilibrium. And so
this thing serves as the new
update rule that makes up the
basis of CGD, or competitive
gradient descent. So this is
just the thing that that serves
as our new update rule. And we
argue that this is a natural
generalization of gradient
descent to multiple agents
without bearing on undue
computational costs or anything
nasty like that. Okay, so that's
how we actually go about our,
our optimization procedure. And
that, it turns out that the Nash
equilibrium of this game,
actually is the exact solution
to the PDE. So So there's
actually no conflict there that
that's actually a nice
mathematical fact that can be
proven. Okay, so how does this
thing perform, I report that
this is such a such a nice idea
or something that, I guess I
should show some evidence that
it has some some nice features.
So here, what we do is the
number of forward we count the
number of forage passes instead
of the number of epochs because
in the sequence procedure, when
asked to account for this
Hutcheon vector, a product,
this, which is associated with
these cross terms that I
mentioned that that makes CGD
what it is, instead of just
simultaneous gradient descent,
so instead, in order to barely
take, take into account the
computational cost, we count the
number of forward passes as
opposed to the number of epochs.
And then we plot that against LT
relative error, which is
nominally what you've actually
care about. And we see that even
on A to D Poisson problem, a
nice, smooth one, nothing
particularly nasty about it over
about 123, like four orders of
magnitude, the pin instance has
the traditional pin trained with
regular gradient descent here,
with Adam, basically, with its
special update rule has
decreased by less than an order
of magnitude over all of those
forward passes in terms of LC
relative error, whereas the C
pen is able to get down to
single precision error. So this
is carried out on single
precision hardware. So this is
actually as good as we can hope
to do. And it does it in an
efficient way, as well. So so it
works here nicely. And then the
other argument that one, maybe
thinking about making is is
along the lines of, well, what
about, you're saying you're
using Atom will maybe I should
just be using some orders, other
special optimizer and that will
take care of the problem. And we
we actually did an ablation
study on a whole slew of
different algorithms, both the
most popular ones and other ones
that people more modern ones
that people argue for. And we
found that this red curve, which
is the one that I presented
before, called a CGD, which,
where the A isn't particularly
important, but the point is that
it outperforms in a quite
meaningful way. All of these
other other things, other
optimizers, which is great. And
I also mentioned the difference
between forward passes and
epochs or iterations. So you
see, if we actually just take
into account iterations, then
the then our method here, and
red looks even better. But I
think that's a bit of an unfair
way of thinking about it. But I
put it there just for reference.
Okay, I have one more slide, I
think. And it's on NewBay.
Stokes. So there's been all
sorts of efforts on trying to
train the VA Stokes, and all
sorts of papers just about
training pins on the VA Stokes.
And so we thought we would give
it a go. And so, my argument
here is that over all of these
orders of magnitude of forward
passes, basically the pen is not
training at all. So this is
being trained on a to solve a
steady cavity flow problem, a
lid driven cavity flow problem.
And it decreases in relative
error by like a factor of have
like to over all of these
forward iterations, the physics
and form neural network without
them. And to be clear again, I'm
only showing the best results
for the physics and form neural
networks with for the various
optimizers. I'm not showing the
ones that do worse. And but for
the C pen, we do get
convergence. It's a bit noisy,
which I have some ideas about
why that may be but suffice it
to say that it does seem to be
converging, albeit quite slowly.
So that This requires a bit more
attention about what could be
going on here. But it has some
similar characteristics. Okay,
so. So that's basically the end
of my talk. And I hope I left
enough time for questions. The
key takeaways here is that
there's a training problem that
is associated with this, this
squared loss function, and that
remedying the squared loss
function is not maybe as trivial
as it seems. And it involves
sort of actually changing the
architecture of how one goes
about solving this problem. And
using sort of a little bit more
specialized optimization
methods, there are a bunch of
good results that we have for
other equations that I wouldn't
burden you with showing you
solutions for the burgers
equation, Schrodinger LM con
equation, so on and so forth. So
we do quite well for those as
well. And, and the new guy
Stokes also does well but needs
a bit more attention that we're
looking into. So the code for
this is openly available under
MIT license, you're welcome to,
to have it and play around with
it if you if you see fit. So I'd
like to thank you for your time
and for the invitation. I hope
this was in any way interesting.
And of course, happy to take
your questions.
Thank you. Thank you so much for
the wonderful talk, Spencer,
very informative and easy to
follow. My opinion. And also
there were like tons of
discussions in the follow every
single things. But let's let's
do this in q&a session. Let's
give a you know, the chance to
ask questions in you know, in
verbally. Hopefully their sound
works. Let's start with a Mark
Miller. If you're okay to unmute
yourself and ask your question
directly, that'd be wonderful.
Sure, maybe I'll just ask the
last one great talk. I wasn't
able to follow all of it. But I
really enjoyed it. So I had a
silly question here towards the
end. What do you have a sense of
maybe what the total flop count
is for solutions via sea pin
versus traditional numerical
solutions? The same quality?
Yeah, good question. So we try
to take that into account with
our business of forward passes
versus iterations here. So
actually, what's going into this
forward pass computation is we
actually we aren't taking into
account per se, the exact lob
count, because that could could
become a bit more complicated
one thinks about that people are
doing you would normally do this
on GPUs. So I'm not sure that
that flop count, per se, is the
perfect metric. But um, but
instead, what we do is we just
take into account the nominal
number of sort of operations
that are required in order to do
the Hessian vector product,
which is the main thing that
actually changes the cost
between the regular pin and the
C pen. So that's the main
difference. And that is the
thing that we add to the cost,
which gives this difference
between the plot on the left and
the plot on the right, in terms
of shifting this red curve to
the right, as well as the yellow
curve, that's somewhat less less
important.
Okay, Mark, Mark is talking
about the traditional numerical
methods like the finite element,
finite difference, by the way?
Oh, are you talking it? Oh,
sorry. If you're Yeah. I'm
totally totally misunderstood.
It's one, it's one I totally get
all the time. So I can. So yeah,
yeah. So your question to that
is, if I understand correctly,
is, well, what if I want to just
solve the same problem using a
finite element method to solve
the PDE? The same way. So I, I
totally sympathize with everyone
that wants to do this. And I
actually suggest you do it. If
you have a traditional solver to
solve via finite elements or
something, your 2d Poisson
equation and you're happy with
that, there will actually be
much faster to deal with that
than to deal with training a pin
and solving it that way. Not
only will you get smaller errors
in your traditional solver, but
you will solve it faster. Now,
the ends what I what I sort of
hit here and maybe I should have
shouldn't have is that the real
value in these pins things in my
view, and maybe other people
have other views, but the main
value is that these things are
useful for many query problems,
many query meaning that I can
train this pin to also be be
parametric. So you know, you can
imagine the flow over an
airfoil. And then I train this
pin on a whole bunch a whole
bunch of PDs where the where the
parameter is, say the angle of
attack. And now I can probe that
thing as basically for free
because the thing is represented
as this small, compact, nice
little neural network. But if
you want to solve a million
finite elements, solve the
finite element equations a
million times for different
angles of attack, then then I
would argue that that's, that's
not really a very fruitful way
to go. And the more promising
area here is these many query
problems. Super, thanks. Thanks
so much. Really enjoyed it.
Thank you.
Thank you. Let's go to magic
magic. View.
Hello, can you hear me?
Yep. Yeah.
So I didn't actually write any
questions in the chat. But I can
ask you a question if that's
okay. Yes, thanks for a great
talk, actually, I mean, I did a
study feels a little bit
different from many other
applications. So it's nice to
get to the root of the problem
with pins. My question is, so
the problems that you showed
here, like day to day problems?
I'm just wondering, do you think
finding the best optimizer will
solve all the problems with pins
or using neural networks to
solve PDS? For instance, for
let's say, problems that they
have time component, or 3d or
where you have high frequencies
and things like that? Yeah, I
guess my question is, like,
what? So I see, they can be one
problem with optimization,
right. And they can be one
problem with neural net for not
being expressive enough to solve
every kind of PDE video with. So
just wanted wondering about your
comments, you know, like your
thoughts on that? Okay. Yes,
thank
you for your question. I think I
understand it. So the so there's
a couple of things first, number
one, I should say, I don't
purport. And I hope I didn't
give the impression that I that
we're somehow solving every pin
problem that exists, just maybe
a couple of the ones that people
have been noticing often. And
that seems to be important to
get into the bottom of some of
these other things. So that's,
that's the deal with this, this
conditioning that can be solved
via a mini max type of
architecture and the competitive
optimizer. So that can be what
solved there. Now, regarding
your sort of other questions,
whether one is whether whether
one is thinking about higher
dimensional problems. So the
part of the reason I actually
didn't solve show fighter higher
dimensional problems is that
higher dimensional problems are
actually easier for a pin like
thing, or really any type of
neural network type
architecture, because they don't
suffer from the curse of
dimensionality in the same way
that a traditional solver would.
So if you had, for example, and
a lot of people do this, and
perhaps it's a bit unfair to for
them to do so. But point is that
as you go to higher and higher
dimensions, so if I think of
like the 10 D Poisson problem,
all of a sudden a neural network
type solution for that problem
actually looks very, very
competitive compared to any type
of traditional solution to that
problem. Because as the, the the
expressivity of the neural
network remains intact, but the
expressivity or the amount of
operations that one would have
to do to solve this in a in a
sort of normal numerical methods
way does not, and it scales to
the power of that dimension. So
that's a nasty problem. And And
actually, that's another place
maybe if I were to add another
bullet point, down here to this
slide, it would be also useful
for many dimensional problems.
And so if those are interests of
up to you, then things like
these types of neural network
expressivity, things are quite
attractive. The other point you
made was just regarding
expressivity in terms of what if
my, my solution to my PDE has,
let's say, some really nasty
features some highly escalatory
features or something like that?
Does the neural network have
enough expressivity in order to
accommodate for those kinds of
solutions? At least if that, if
I'm understanding the? And I
think so there's a couple of
things. One is that this,
there's this idea of the neural
networks serve as universal
approximator. So and So which I
think in many cases is used as a
bit of a red herring. But the
point is that, but but the point
is still true, is that for a
sufficiently deep and wide
neural network, any type of
solution can be expressed. So so
that's, that is true. And now,
now what in more practical
terms, if one had a really nasty
equation, and what would How big
would the neural network have to
be? And would it be worth making
a neural network that large in
order to get that kind of
expressivity is a question that
I'm not really prepared to
answer, but it would, but in
some limit, it would be able to
do so.
Interesting. Thank you. Thank
you for your comments. Great
talk.
Thank you.
Okay, thank you. Let's move on
to repairing. I know, he just
commented on it. But let's give
him a chance. Oh, wait. Thanks.
Thank you. Thank you. If I can
ask some questions. This is a
very good talk. I'm very
interested in this topic. I
think my first question is up,
actually, and that's on the
slide you you're showing here, I
think, at the very beginning of
your talk, you'll set some good
features up of pin, because you
don't need the much data and you
have some information in the
back propagation. I think I
didn't hear that very well. Can
you? Can you please comment down
that again?
Absolutely. Yeah. So this comes
down to the crux of what a pin
actually is, which is the idea
that I, what I want to do is I
want to solve a PDE. So what I'm
showing here is a toy PDE a
Poisson problem. So I have the
Laplacian of u equals F. And so
I'm just basically sticking this
thing into the loss function or
the error, the mismatch, the
result, the mismatch in the
residual, basically, is going
into the loss function. And
these are just the first time
here is just associated with
boundary conditions. So maybe we
can maybe we can forget that for
the moment. So that's the idea
of a pen. And then the reason
that this all sort of works out
nicely is because one can, one
doesn't need any data, because
one can obtain these
derivatives. So in this case, I
need the second derivatives with
respect with respect to the
independent variable operating
on you in order to compute the
Laplacian, right? But the thing
is, through backpropagation, I
can get, I can just basically do
auto grad to get all of those
derivatives for free. So this
comes to the case where, where I
don't actually need some sort of
data or anything, I can
automatically compute what those
derivatives should be. And I can
just take them into the loss
function. So basically, back
propagating through the neural
network to compute what the what
the derivatives are. So at
times, you can approximate or
you can put up any sort of PDE
into this thing.
Gotcha. Thank you. My second
question is, I think you showed
one of the problem in not
achieving high accuracy in pin
is the loss function. So you
have you because we monitor this
read you do? Yeah, especially in
this linear algebra sense, a U
equals to F. I think a lot of
traditional methods like Jim RAS
is also a minimization problem
based on residual the based on
the residual norm. Doesn't seem
is too much a problem for Krylov
method or other traditional
numerical method. But it seems
like the conditioning is a
really a pain. In this context.
Do you have comments on that?
Yes, right. So good point. Yeah.
So yeah, so one can argue about
whether or not whether or not
this problem of this this sort
of squared condition number is
pervasive to all minimize
errors, or whether one can just
somehow pick a better minimizer
and be okay. Part of the thing
here is that this is, and that's
part of the limitations of this
linear algebra example is that
is it just just a linear algebra
example. And if one wanted to do
this on the actual sort of
through the neural network, then
then something like Krylov
subspace method would not be
appropriate. And MGM res would
suffer in the same way. So
basically, the only way, as far
as I'm aware, to get round this
is to give away the P equals two
norm to give or to give away any
P, P even norm. And, and to
settle with like a P one norm,
but that has its own problems to
settle for an odd for an odd
norm. That that would be a
solution. But I think but it
comes with other problems that I
think would not be conducive to,
to the type of things that
people usually care about. Okay.
Thank you. Thank you.
Okay, thank you. Let's move on
to John Ragosa. That's giving
you a chance to ask question,
John,
a thank you. Great talk. I liked
it a lot, very interested in
paint. I would have lots of
issues with paint. So maybe I'll
send you an email later. But let
me just ask you a couple of
questions. If there's time. Have
you tried cases where the PD has
greatly varying coefficients?
Let's say for example, as in,
you know, heat conduction
problem that you have
conductivity is in different
materials and the conductivity
is maybe vary by factor, let's
say 1000. So, really severely
heterogeneous cases can see the
pins approach seems to always
find solutions that are overly
two diffusive. And they'll have
sharp gradients. And I'd be
interested to know what you
think of those more real life
situations with with
heterogeneous problems.
Ah, yeah,
we have a problem that can't,
that you can't normalize the
scale. So yeah, I guess you have
these nasty sort of rough
coefficients that you're talking
about, then? The quick answer is
no, I haven't tried it. And
maybe I should, um, and whether
or not I suspect that something
like what I presented is somehow
a cure to that or not. I don't I
don't know. I mean, the, like
your your comments about the the
fact that your your pin result
gives on this type of highly
heterogeneous problem gives a
say, overly diffusive solution
or something like this. It's
not, I guess, one would first
have to know what what to really
attribute that problem to, which
can be a challenge. But I mean,
it's not clear to me
immediately, whether that's due
to maybe whether or not the pin
has been sufficiently trained.
Or, and so the loss function is
sufficiently low, because
another thing that is, is, at
least intellectually interesting
about pins is that they can come
up with solutions to PDE s,
because there's no data
involved, right? So they can
come up with solutions to PDS
that are also that are that are
solutions. But they just aren't
the one that you were thinking
you would get. So so so people
have actually used this to find
to like show that maybe you can
actually get like non unique
solutions to things like the
navier stokes equations. So
actually, a recent, some recent
papers on on the Millennium
prize type problems for TVA
Stokes, have touched upon that.
So that's another possibility.
But unfortunately, I can't
really speak much more to, to
the to the type of problem
you're talking about.
No worries, I think I'd send you
an email later today. Maybe this
weekend, I'll tell you a few
things. But what I'm, what I'm
doing and what the issues I'm
having. Now, I have another
quick question. If you think Sue
allows me to skyrocket quick.
Okay, very, very quick. What do
you think? What do you think of
training the new generation of
graduate students on those
tools? Should they also learn
traditional methods? Or is it
always is going to be a thing of
the past? I'm just curious what
your opinion is on this
trend training them to do what
to do these kinds of neural
network type things? Yeah, yeah.
You know, maybe maybe there will
be a less emphasis on learning,
you know, finite elements, find
a different type of themes of,
you know, what we call
traditional methods. What do you
think with this takeover? Is
there room for techniques? Who?
Well, there's some some tension
in between the two? What's your
opinion?
I think people are trying these
things, because they partially
because they're trendy, and
partially because they've run
out of other options. But of
course, yes, young young folks
coming into grad school, want to
try the trendy things? That's,
that has always been the case.
And and, and pins is definitely
not the first example of that.
And sometimes these things prove
to stand sort of the test of
time, so to speak, and, and
sometimes they do not. So I
guess I don't claim to have any,
any more clairvoyance on the
app. But I do think that I mean,
only boy thing I think is that
anything that involves not
thinking about the math, behind
these things, in some sort of
careful way, is very risky,
because you end up in this
situation where your results may
not be good, and you have no way
to reason about why they aren't
good. And so if you don't
understand the math, then you're
you're really out of luck,
because the neural network also
is opaque so it doesn't offer
you. It doesn't offer you some
sort of something of some other
information in which you can
sort of inform your priors and
make a better choice about a
model or a differential equation
or something like that.
Yeah, thank you so much. Thank
you.
Thank you. Let's move on to
Henry. Henry. Are you there? Oh,
hi. Hi, I'm here. Can you hear
me? Yeah. And you can ask
questions. Oh, sure. Hi. Yeah,
thank you.
Thank you for your talk, I just
wonder if so you use the PD
residual as your loss function
that you want to minimize in
your problem. So I was just
wondering, what are your
thoughts on like, does it make
sense to use like a physics
space functional? By for
example, like for the diffusion
equation, you can define the
thermal dissipation functional?
And then you can just minimize
that to get your solution for
diffusion equation like, what
are your thoughts on using that
as your last function?
Right? So a pin in this context,
at least only purports to be
able to only purports to be
solving a PDE, that is
prescribed and now, while
you're, I think alluding to is
the idea of adding additional
terms that are associated with
the physics that may also be
relevant. And so one can, of
course, pile on these sorts of
additional constraints and terms
in the in soft terms into the
loss function in the hopes of
getting a better result. But
then it's just a matter of what
do you consider a better result?
If what people have been playing
around with this idea, if I go
back to here, what that
basically, there's whole,
there's whole spaces here, where
people are thinking about
physics guided loss functions,
right, all the way down here. So
all of these papers are thinking
about, how do I add things to
that are relevant to the physics
that are maybe aside from just
the PDE? And if there's one
thing that I've learned, it's
that these things are a bit hard
to say? They I think they kind
of missed the point that if the
neural network is, is behaving
appropriately, and in a way that
you expect, then you don't need
these things. And so and so in a
sense, they're kind of stopgap
sort of solutions to get
something that looks kind of how
you want it to look. But if, but
otherwise, if it's if it's not
giving you the solution that you
expect that the know, maybe
there's something more
interesting going on, which is
what we found. And I think, I
think that that's actually why
the things that are shown in the
slides here, have gone sort of
unnoticed for so long, because
people were thinking about these
other types of things, and not
just thinking about, like, what
is like the actual math going on
in this thing.
Okay. Oh, thanks. Thank you.
Okay, let's move to while it are
you, there
is thank you for the
opportunity. And thank you for
the great presentation. I'm
really glad that someone is
finally addressing the loss
functions and the optimization
issues associated with Ben's my
question, my first question is
in regards to the boundary
conditions you're using for the
poisons equation, if you can
describe him briefly.
I believe that we just did.
Periodic? No, I think, no, no,
sorry, just dear slave boundary
conditions are correctly on that
problem.
It will be interesting to see if
you can use some Neumann
boundary conditions with sources
and sinks. Because that could be
a very challenging problem. My
second question is in regards to
mixing other types of loss
losses in the loss function. So
if you had some data, so you
have a different type of, let's
say, a mean squared error with
the min max loss function, is
that something that's possible?
Yes, it's certainly possible,
either a priori, a posteriori. I
mean, that's the other part of
what was actually inside of the,
the, the paper here. So yes, you
certainly can add these other
data, data constraints. So if
you know that, that the data is
whatever it is that you can add,
you can add it to perhaps to
better do better here in terms
of your training and get a
better result. The only concern
that I sometimes have about
mixing and matching these two
things is that the data comes
with its own uncertainties and
whether or not the data is
behaving exactly as the PDE that
you stick in this loss function
is may not be always clear. So
whether or not it's obeying the
exact you know, incompressible,
navier stokes or something to
this effect, is is not always
obvious. And if that is the
case, then you could end up with
this sort of tension between
these two different types of
loss function that may not give
the results you expect. And but
that that's, that's It's like a
pin thing, not necessarily
something specific to the type
of architecture that I was
talking about.
Or Thank you very much. Thanks.
Great talk. Thank you.
Okay, John, we're gonna Are you
there?
Oh,
maybe he's not there. But he
loved the chat in the chat.
Great. Oh, can you please share
the paper and the code in the
chat? Yeah. So well,
I don't have access to the chat
at the moment. But they're,
they're here. And then they'll
be they'll be available there.
They're also just on my website.
So
yeah. All right. Sounds good.
feed you. Are you there?
Just a very generic question. So
Kennedy's idea of min max method
is to a min max problem be
applied to generic regression
problems? Can it be applied to
what? Sorry, say it again?
Regression
over general regression
problems? Um, yes. Yes, it can.
It's just that I'm not sure the
benefits are so obvious. It
depends on what kind of
regression problem you have. But
if Ebina for if the regression
problem is solving is has the
same types of poor conditioning,
then we can certainly
reformulate this sort of loss
function this way. And so that,
yeah, so there's, there's many
applications of this type of
competitive tension that give
that that are useful. And one
can find them in the in the
papers that are referenced in
our paper, of which there are
many. And you can, and you can
have a look and see there, there
really are quite a few. I just
didn't have time to talk about
all of them.
All right. Thank you. Stop here.
Are you there? He's not there.
All right. So that's the all I
have on the chat. But is there
anyone who wants to ask
questions on mute yourself? So
that's a quick question. Yeah,
boy, yeah. Yeah. This
is Andrew Jillette. I really
enjoyed your talk. Thank you.
I'm curious. There's some work
that was like gradient informed
pin where they do slightly
better than pin results by
incorporating gradient
information. Have you compared
your work to that? And if so,
how did it compare?
No, we compared our work to many
different what I would call
training tricks. Where one ads
basically one's trying to
accelerate training or somehow
ameliorate these costs that are
that show up in order to get
better results. And so there's a
whole sort of alphabet soup of
different pin methods. And, and
so it's true that I think these
gradient things do give better
results. There's, there's, I
guess two things I would note,
the first is that none of them
seem to my eyes to actually
address what is the actual
problem. And so I mean, if you
can get a better solution
without addressing the actual
problem, then I think I mean,
that's fine. But I, at the very
least, I wanted to, to note it,
to note that this is what what
what is likely going on. And,
and the other is that these many
of these other sort of training
tricks that, that that one of
which you're alluding to, but
but there are others, like,
like, like mini batching, and
all these other things. We've
tried some of them because
reviewers wanted to see them.
But in principle, they can all
be just added to our method
anyway. So in some sense,
they're in different categories.
Make sense? Thank you. Thank
you.
Sounds good. Well, it's seven
ft. 11. Spencer, thank you so
much for staying with us for the
extra time.
I was able to get to some of
these questions.
Wonderful. Okay, so I'm sure
there are more questions, but
let's wrap up here. And then Oh,
yeah. Say hi to someone is good
to meet you here.
Hope you're having a good time
at Lawrence Livermore on your in
your first week?
Yeah, it is first week. Yeah. I
am having a Good Time hear it.
Yeah. Very good. Awesome. Well,
thank you, Spencer again. Let's
think. Applause one more time.
And yeah, I mean, I hope you
will increase the collaboration
with the Lawrence Livermore
National Lab as well. I mean, as
you do with other other other
national lab, right, or preacher
and the Sandia National Lab,
right, please consider us okay.
So It'd be my pleasure. All
right. Sounds good.
Okay, let me push the stop
button for the recording.